Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this series, we have studied fluid simulations
extensively. But we haven't talked about one
important quantity that describes a fluid,
and this quantity is none other than viscosity.
Viscosity means the resistance of a fluid
against deformation.
The large viscosity of honey makes it highly
resistant to deformation, and this is responsible
for its famous and beautiful coiling effect.
Water, however, does not have a lot of objections
against deformations, making it so easy to
pour it into a glass.
With this piece of work, it is possible to
efficiently simulate the motion of fluids,
and it supports the simulation of a large
range of viscosities.
Viscosities can also change in time. For instance,
physicists know that raising the temperature
will make the viscosity of fluids decrease,
which leads to melting, therefore decreasing
the viscosity in time will lead to a simulation
result that looks exactly like melting.
The technique also supports two-way coupling
where the objects have effects on the fluid
and vice versa.
One can also put multiple fluids with different
densities and viscosities into the same domain
and see how they duke it out.
This is exactly what people need in the industry:
robust techniques that work for small and
large scale simulations with multiple objects,
and material settings that can possibly change
in time.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!